go there go there and say north korea
nuke south korea what should we do
wow i don't you you just go to places
like that why in the world with north
korean guys
they're korean i'm a as a as a person
who was just thinking from the
we have a guy right now that the
conversation i had yesterday two days
ago we have peter pryor here dr peter
prior i don't know if you know who he is
he is the leading expert for weapons of
mass destruction and nuclear weapons and
super emp's and you know experts are
saying if they drop a super emp 70 of
america is going to die within 30 days
sure this is a reality and so there's a
lot of [ __ ] going on today so for me to
sit there and say guys don't worry about
it it's going to be chill nothing's
going to work that's not what they're
saying i don't know where you're going i
just ask you a simple question you're
telling me i'm a question it's
this is not everything though well this
is i'm from iran buddy i'm this is not
coming from a guy that's an although
this is like we're living in atlanta in
america where there's no horse here
there's somebody nukaron half a million
people die between them and iraq yes by
the way yes
by the way because the united states was
funding and supporting
both sides we were given the both sides
in that war if if north korea today okay
so let me let me go back to what you
said you said something here so well if
we take this route and you know here's
what's going to be happening and you
know they're going to see us as the good
guy saying hey guys don't do this etc
etc okay
if if your last name is trump
when you go to school but you're not
donald trump but your last name is trump
if you go somewhere you're going to
school or you're doing business you
introduce yourself as
hi i'm barron trump are you going to be
judged yeah yeah okay
if your last name is kennedy and say hi
i'm robert kennedy jr are you going to
be judged sure of course um your last
name is clinton i'm chelsea clinton how
are you do you immediately go to uh oh
i'm dealing with a trump a kennedy or a
clinton yes okay
if you
are representing a country whose name is
the united states of america
and you're going to say listen guys
we've changed
we're nice people now but that's not
what we don't just we don't you know we
don't want to do any of this anymore
let's just kind of kick it and let's
have a good relationship together and
let's do this say you change
say we change philosophically
dramatically to go to a libertarian
philosophy
i see the only way that works if
everybody is joining that camp china's
gonna say you're good for you guys go
ahead russia's gonna say
okay awesome nice people uh your current
system means in about four to eight
years new guy's going to take over what
you're doing right now and he's going to
go back to whatever was in the past
before the dystopian future is happening
now well you're acting like this is some
future the chinese right now are
dominating us in places like africa and
southeast asia because we are wasting
our time fighting wars in afghanistan
they love it listen they love it they
love what we're doing so here's the
thing
well let me just say okay there's two
errors here that you can control for
right and i think you're focusing on one
and not the other and the other is more
the reality of the situation right now
so you can make the argument that if we
kind of back off that that's less of a
disincentive for other people to to take
over because they don't think we're
going to be as forceful strong what's
actually going on more in in reality
right now is that we are provoking a lot
of these other countries into some of
their actions i mean look we expanded
nato all the way up to the russian
border and then we're shipping in money
uh weapons and money and also were
instrumental in a ukrainian coup in 2014
all before vladimir putin ended up in
invading i don't think the lesson here
is necessarily that oh if we back off
he's going to invade we also might
provoke him by going further and i think
this could i agree okay fine so there's
poland today said that they're
considering uh joining nato right so
it's like
now now things are escalating higher and
higher rather than what we want which is
to de-escalate the situation okay so on
on top of that look do you honestly
think let's think about this does does
vladimir putin or does china do they
want us out of afghanistan or in
afghanistan for another 20 years they
want to say they want us in for another
20 years they are not looking at what
we've done with this empire and saying
oh great they bankrupted themselves and
destroyed their culture maybe we could
be next on that i think they'd rather
wait china's been going around and
investing with countries while we've
been occupying them militarily we have
made the hugest blunder strategically in
the 21st century of handing the 21st
century to china we need to stop doing
that what we should be doing is saying
yes we're going to pull back we can
trade with people invest with them we're
going to have the freest economy here we
can have and be 100 times richer than
china and they're not something we're
going to have to worry about i'd much
rather go in that direction than in the
direction of look it's like this anytime
i understand you're saying that you're
not advocating for us provoking them
you're talking about how do we make sure
that we defend but once you create this
entrenched power
this is where it's going to go you know
the old cold warriors back in the day
before the fall of the soviet union uh
guys like bill buckley he used to say
you know i basically agree with
libertarians you know in theory but look
we got the soviet union so we have to
have this big military-industrial
complex in his word we in his words we
needed a totalitarian bureaucracy within
our own shores just to fight off the
soviet union to fight this cold war and
then when the when the soviet union fell
in 1991 they all went great military
industrial complex over now we can go
back to being a normal country oh no of
course they didn't then they went oh we
got to go see about saddam hussein we
got to go see about kosovo we got to go
see and just wars continued on and on
and on because once you have this
entrenched government power well this is
how they make money this is how they
expand their power so it's not i don't
think you can have it perfectly down the
middle we're this big bad policeman of
the world but we only do good by
everyone it's too corrupting this is
what the founders all said this is why
we can't go around the world looking for
monsters to slay we have to stay here 90
of the world is in really bad shape it's
not what first world people live like
and i think you know that it's not that
is a sad difficult reality but the best
thing we can be is be a city on a hill
be an example to these other countries
let them learn from us if we're richer
and happier and more prosperous and more
free other countries will try to emulate
us we can enforce it at the barrel of a
gun and it's not gonna work and stop
subsidizing our threats well that's for
sure whether it's the cia funding the
next terror group that we haven't even
heard of yet like they did with isis
like they did with al qaeda whether it's
uh uh whether it's like we're talking
about subsidizing essentially
subsidizing the economies of of russia
and china uh through bad uh regulatory
and tax uh structures here that make it
harder to do business here uh whether
it's i mean
what started with the middle east
operation ajax eisenhower because he
didn't like the democratically elected
uh government that was in iran uh he
replaced it he did operation ajax which
was the cia going in and deposing the
democratically elected government
replacing it with the shah who was very
unpopular right and so he comes in and
comes back in with a vengeance and that
leads to the the the uh the um the
revolution yes the iranian revolution
okay so now you have the ayatollah's in
charge
this is what happens
when we're saying what are we going to
do about it what we should do about it
is look at how we got here and then how
we can fix it if there were a stop china
from invading any one button i don't
think anyone here wouldn't press it but
there isn't what there is is a
military-industrial complex that has
proven itself really bad at doing things
other than making money for cronies and
corporate interests uh killing lots and
lots of people and making us all less
safe in the process do you think there's
a likely that we're gonna have another
hitler
no
are you seeing in the states or or in
the world i don't know worldwide not not
in the states do you think there's a
likelihood that there will be
possibly another hitler i think it's
unlikely i mean there's there's it's not
impossible look i think you have three
figures in the 20th century who kind of
rise to that level of evil uh in uh
hitler stalin and mao yeah and um so the
idea of having another one of them
i think that might be a type of unique
evil that was somewhat unique to that
time in this post-industrialized world
in the in the aftermath of world war one
um it it i think it would be much harder
to pull off today in a world where
information travels so much quicker
around the world that doesn't mean it's
impossible and i have weapons too
nuclear weapons also
i think it is likely i i want to say i
think it is likely and we have to look
at what led to the hitler and stalin and
mao which by the way it wasn't them as
individuals if it hadn't been them it
would have been someone else okay so in
hitler uh we had the weimar republic
which did uh out-of-control spending
also the after-effects of world war one
world war ii was basically an extension
of world war one there was a
what 20-year truce that happened there
but in the in the meantime you had the
allied countries that were just
destroying germany's economy germany's
government was spending money out of
control and it led to the money being
worth absolutely nothing and that
allowed a man mad man like hitler to
come in because he provided a stark
contrast to what everyone else was
saying and that allowed that to happen
and it was our it was also our federal
reserve i mean if you look at in i think
it was in 28 the nazis of the nazi party
destroyed in the elections in germany
then they came back again in the special
uh election was in in 30 i think i might
have right around these years and they
came back and they took a bunch of power
this was at the nazis gotten power and
it was all because of the great
depression which was caused by our
bubble bursting here that the federal
reserve created and then all of the debt
got called in from germany it destroyed
the german people and of course
enforcing the treaty of versailles as
you said look woodrow wilson in world
war one said we have to make the world
safer democracy right kind of this
argument we had despots in europe so we
have to go there and overthrow them and
we overthrow that you know the the kings
and queens the monarchs are all gone in
europe and england in name only but the
monarchs are gone in england and then in
the aftermath of world war one you got
adolf hitler vladimir lenin and joseph
stalin and those monarchs looked pretty
good
at that point well i want to bring out
one quick point though i'm not against
fighting
i'm marine i'm not afraid of violence
i'm trained to be
tons of my brothers and sisters have
gone over there and lost arms and legs
but my worry is why am i marines leaving
their legs in the streets of i don't
know kandahar or baghdad if i'm going to
leave my legs in the streets in the
streets of manhattan i'll fight for my
city i'll fight for my country i'll
fight for my nation i'm not afraid of
that but why are we sending literally
millions of men and women that go fight
overseas and when they come back we
shoot them like garbage anyway and then
we don't even know why they die they
don't know why their lives are ruined
this is not the right answer right if
they're gonna die if and i'm telling i
know these people they would lay their
life down and when i was a marine i
would have ordered men to their death or
i would have gone to my death because
ronald reagan who was my first man in
chief would have told me to do so and
many of them would have would do it but
why are we doing it in for in in
afghanistan literally for nothing
in iraq literally for nothing the active
active duty military people uh vote and
send more money to the most anti-war
presidential candidates ron paul ron
paul got more money from active duty
military members than every other
republican combined in 2008 and 2012
donald trump got far more support from
the military than hillary clinton when
he was taking a more dovish stance in
2016. the people who actually have to
fight these wars are the ones who know
what's up and they don't want to do it
johnson was popular what veterans do
yeah
he got something like double digits
right uh i've been to uh almost all 50
states at this point in just the last
two three years during the campaign and
after the campaign working on on you or
the power and growing that now um
doing that i've met with people across
the country i would say that at any
event that i do
anywhere from 20 to 40 percent of the
people that come out are either active
duty or veterans who are coming that
what brought them into libertarianism
was either me or someone else dave or or
larry or ron paul or whoever else
telling them that we were against the
wars of intervention we were against the
military-industrial complex we were
against the veterans administration uh
single it's not even single-payer
government-run healthcare system that's
that's completely destroying their
health the help that they were promised
when they came back um
that's what's bringing them to it this
system isn't working it makes us less
safe it wastes a bunch of money it
scores countless scores of people are
dying overseas many more are coming here
and dying their veterans are people are
going over uh active duty troops are go
over there and dying the ones that are
fortunate enough to come home not in a
flag draped casket come home with ptsd
traumatic brain injuries all sorts of
health problems they're given the worst
form of health care in this country the
veterans administration uh one out of
every ten homeless people is homeless
one out of every ten people in this
video or it's a veteran whatever every
ten homeless people as a veteran one out
of every 10 uh prisoners is a veteran is
actually higher than that now and this
is as a direct result of this system so
when we're saying do something yes we
should do something and that something
is looking at the root cause of what
even caused a communist regime to be
powerful in the first place and stop
doing that so if you like this clip and
you want to watch another one click
right here and if you want to watch the
entire podcast click right here
[Music]
you